and a couple of things we need to modify
yeah I've seen a couple of them here
like here's only for the beatitudes
jean-michel Aires is a self-confessed
perfectionist I mean is this this is
part of my job and I really enjoy it
here because I love cars I love sports
cars and Galeras has been the CEO of
Lotus for only nine months this car is a
product of his new management style when
it goes to Geneva it needs to be as I
want it to be perfect yeah
Lotus has been losing money fast in 2013
the company posted a 168 million pound
loss in fact over the past two decades
it's never made money you see it now we
need to we need to we need to rework
that we need to work on that is when
galas took over there were talks Lotus
might not survive that he's had his work
cut out from we have a clear plan yeah
the plan is that we want to be
operational cash flow positive next
financial year which stands on the 1st
of April we want to be profitable a year
later and the Evora 400 is the key it's
lotuses fastest-ever road-car 0 to 100
4.1 seconds cost approximately 70,000
pounds puts it in the same price range
as a Porsche 911
in fact the car mimics Giles's
management style cut down lightened
no-nonsense
but in order to get the car out we had
to increase revenue and we had
absolutely also to reduce cost and one
of the ways of reducing cost is to
reduce our head
the less made 240 workers redundant in a
company which had around 1200 employees
that's a deep cut he argues the job
losses were essential to turning the
company around and the good news is that
in order to ability scar we are going to
hire another 150 people in the next four
months so moving up again in terms of
person to reach profitability by 2017
Lotus needs to sell a third more cars
this year this financial year we're
going to move up to a $2,000 here and
next year he's going to be at 3,000 and
twisters 3,000 cars we are going to
achieve profitability galas born in
Luxembourg but with a long history with
German car makers he's shaking things up
bringing attention to detail and
discipline to the company but he says
we're lacking now he has to see how the
public responds to the Evora the car he
calls his baby